Jews have won three of the last four
games they've also won seven of their
last eight at heart
Wade misses on the run rebounded perks
with 15 seconds left in the quarter
Wade Wade is Dan and they are stopping
play out of fear that Wade has hit his
head Scott Foster said let's make sure
it's not a concussion situation like he
hit was more of his upper back area fell
unevenly there on that shot attempt
scary moment for Dwyane Wade and Miami
just under 11 seconds left here in the
first quarter this place has gone silent
good to see wage head up as he talks to
the head athletic trainer of the Miami
Heat Jay Sabol and now wait as turnover
his back and as being helped out and a
sigh of relief
here in Sacramento and stretching all
the way to South Florida and all points
between Wade walking off under his own
power and heading to the heat locker
[Applause]
this game could battle your thoughts huh
oh boy I mean it's a such a momentum
thing Ellen
shooting grant wait speaking of shooting
makes it an 11-point game again the
sequel was the largest lead right side
stops Paul Astana gets the rebound wait
in transition three-pointer the Miami
Heat shooting quick quick wouldn't
missing another car
Boston D Wade is a blast in the past but
do you know he's not one of the three or
four best players in the world anymore
but he plenty good